[Música]
tiempo para la información económica en
france 24 que acompaña nuestro
periodista especializado jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a hablar de ese
fortalecimiento del dólar frente a las
monedas de américa latina una pregunta
que se hace mucho nuestros televidentes
porque está subiendo tanto el dólar hay
muchos motivos juan te voy a mencionar
algunos los principales la subida de los
tipos de interés en eeuu la caída de los
precios internacionales de las materias
primas y algunos confinamientos por kobe
19 en china los inversores temen al
riesgo en un contexto de desaceleración
de la actividad productiva a nivel
global esto repercute en la demanda de
algunas materias primas como el cobre o
el petróleo del que países importantes
en américa latina son exportadores estos
movimientos externos son determinantes
para la cotización del dólar en la
región así lo explica el economista
alexander ríos de inversión ese
movimiento se puede explicar
perfectamente desde las expectativas de
inflación que están ocurriendo no
solamente en latinoamérica en europa
sino principalmente en eeuu esa
inflación hace que los principales
determinísticos que se utilizan para
tomar decisiones sobre la tasa de
interés de eeuu se vayan al alza
entonces para que cualquier personal o
pueblo pueda entender las tasas de
interés llaman los los capitales más
cuando se es una moneda fuerte y refugio
como el dólar por tanto si la inflación
sube en eeuu subirán las tasas de
interés en eeuu y eso empujará el dólar
al alza a nivel global por supuesto las
monedas latinoamericanas son de las más
endebles en ese sentido y eso hace que
nuestras monedas tengan una mayor
volatilidad que frente al promedio
global
jorge algunos vinculan esta caída de las
humanidades latinoamericanas con cambios
políticos en algunos países que está
pasando bueno tiene que ver las
turbulencias políticas a nivel local
pero no es la causa principal en el caso
de colombia y chile que viven
importantes cambios políticos están en
el ranking de moneda más depreciadas
frente al dólar el banco central de
chile anunció esta semana una
intervención en el mercado cambiario con
un monto de hasta 25 mil millones de
dólares para tratar de frenar la caída
del peso las monedas de estos
importantes exportadores
latinoamericanos alcanzaron mínimos
históricos- le preguntamos a nuestro
invitado porque el peso colombiano y
chileno caen mientras el real brasileño
por ejemplo se aprecia esto respondió no
es un secreto para nadie que colombia y
chile atraviesan momentos políticos de
cambio bastante drásticos y
particularmente chile más que colombia
pero ya sabemos que en colombia es la
primera vez que se elige
un partido de izquierda un poco más
agresiva que un partido de
centroizquierda y todo eso es una
variable como cualquier otra que le
involucra incertidumbre a la economía
entonces para que entendamos la primera
variable es la incertidumbre política
eso puede generar una aceleración en dos
procesos evaluativos pero ahí no queda
todo el efecto también resulta que
colombi chile últimamente han tenido
problemas en su balanza comercial
colombia viene muy sensible en términos
de deficitarios y muy sensible
aumentando muchísimo las importaciones
lo cual nos hace traer inflación lo cual
nos crea un desbalance fiscal y eso nos
vuelve también vulnerables en términos
de cambios de moneda extranjera en
cambio de de tasas internacionales
entonces chile y colombia comparten esos
dos escenarios una pequeña debilidad en
balanza comercial y una incertidumbre
popol y política porque no ha pasado
esta devaluación en países como perú y
como ven brasil principalmente este
último puesto que las últimas métricas
de este año muestra que por ejemplo
brasil está exportando
una cuantía mayor que las importaciones
que está haciendo digamos que brasil
está mostrando cierta resistencia a las
importaciones lo cual está favoreciendo
un poco a esa incertidumbre
internacional 'jorge el dólar arrasa con
las monedas latinoamericanas pero
también con otras monedas del mundo
incluso una noticia de que está casi a
la paridad con el euro bueno vemos una
reacción similar en el mundo
principalmente en europa con temores a
una recesión sobre todo por la cercanía
con con la guerra en ucrania la moneda
única europea cayó por debajo de la
relación con el dólar por primera vez en
20 años los analistas prevén que hasta
que no se mejoren las perspectivas
económicas la caída del euro en relación
con el dólar seguirá en decadencia
mientras que el riesgo para américa
latina es que sufre un crecimiento más
lento debido a que la inflación comienza
a calar en el poder adquisitivo de los
consumidores y también las condiciones
financieras se endurecen le preguntamos
alexander ríos hasta cuándo seguirá este
fortalecimiento del dólar y esto
respondió es un efecto mixto ella
esperar que para la inflación es esperar
que eeuu se desacelere un poco y busque
volver a acelerar
esperar que se baje un poco las
presiones inflacionarias internacionales
y por supuesto que cada país genere las
condiciones de seguridad y confianza
fiscal para atraer esa inversión porque
podemos ver el caso por ejemplo de
argentina que indiferente pase el ciclo
bueno o malo en el exterior su ciclo
interno no genera confianza
inversionista y esto hace que el dólar
suba sin parada o resultado con la
información económica muchas gracias
[Música]